[Music]
so John Landsman founder of momentum is
founder was that the phone
yes okay heavily associated with
momentum and and with Jeremy Corbyn tell
me where you come from tell me what your
background is well I I grew up in this
may sound unlikely my parents voted
conservative you know when I was a kid
it was suburban household they were in
the rag trade Jewish fairly Orthodox you
know not very Orthodox because the shop
was open on Saturday and that's not a
bit more than high days and holidays and
I I suppose you know I was a child of
the sixties I was rebellious by nature I
was very taken with you know the kind of
hippie ideas when I was a kid and I
thought my parents were very reactionary
I've come later to a different view of
my parents I mean I feel you know you
don't completely realize these things
till they're dead actually yeah and I
think they gate they contributed a lot
in spite of being tourists to my
politics because my mum came from a very
poor background she grew up you know
with her sister and her parents in one
room in Kilburn they shared a kitchen
there was a loo the bath was a tin bath
under the under the kitchen table and my
mum was bright she got a scholarship
Jesus during the war she got a
scholarship to a very grammar squeezers
before the 44 education act got
scholarship to a Grammar School
and she was very bright but she she had
to leave when she was 14 to living and
dad my dad well he was born above the
the shop where which was the family
business in Hackney I think small
businessman Tori type of value exactly
exactly I mean he was a it was very much
a One Nation Tori
he was very Pro public services he
eventually ended up being a Tory
counselor in Hackney and it was very
conscientious
so is your is your lefty ism in part I
sort of fall out against your dad well
he actually didn't join the Tory Party
until after I joined the Labour Party
our John I approached it when I was 16
and he joined the Tory Party as a
reaction to me oh right okay his dad
actually I think was a liberal vote and
but my mum was very encouraging of me
you know she used to take me she loved
the theater she you know when she even
though you know she left school she she
she was working in Hoban actually and
she used to go and queue up for the for
the you know the tickets on the day and
she loved her fifties take me to the
theatre as a kid so so what was it what
was it the 60s that made so I'm trying
to work out where the lefty John
Landsman appears it's possible so you go
Tory councillor Paschal I'm not holding
out against you I'm just talking just
trying to hold this is true this is just
trying to get there I
my mum loved ruiner she read a hell of a
lot she was incredibly well-read she
encouraged me I read a lot and I read a
lot of stuff that stimulated political
thinking and and a lot of it was was
Jewish history of anti-semitism through
the ages of persecution of the Holocaust
and you know that turned me towards
having very strong views about injustice
my parents really encourage debate at
the dinner table you know the Friday
night you know the Sabbath meal was
always a family occasion and we would
always argue often about politics from
when I was very young I know is that
there was that time in the sixties where
you described and particularly with
Israel is there was a great deal of hope
about the holes
I guess Zionist project and this was a
sort of it had a relationship to
socialism it had a sort of there was
stuff there was something about that
sort of pioneering of Israel I the
pioneering aspect of it was really
important I was incredibly attracted to
the idea of the kibbutz of communal
living of of the lava return to the land
and simplicity these things were much
more appealing than what I got at school
which I hated actually it was an
unpleasant experience you know I you
know I traveled a long way to school I
didn't have any you know none of my
friends lived anywhere near me it was
very isolating it meant that I read a
lot because I didn't have anything else
to do in the evenings once I got home
but you know it was it was it was the
hostility to impression and injustice
which first got me interested in
politics and what turned me to the
Labour Party really was the experience
of the three-day week Ted Heath the -
strikes of 72 and 74 and in 1974 in the
February election I wasn't even 16 and
someone knocked on my front door
canvassing in that in that election I
answered the door and it led me to join
the Labour to go out and deliver
leaflets in that election I joined the
Labour Party shortly after that election
I was an active member and canvassing
mother time we got to the second
election in I'd said before
and you you went and spent some time and
Accords didn't you and how did that
change your view about Israel and your
Jewishness that's it it changed my view
about the returned to the land working
in chicken houses for three days
shoveling shoveling chicken [ __ ]
it was liquid on day one and it had
turned to dust by day three and I don't
know which was worse the smell on the
smell was worse on day one but you had
to breathe it in on day three I became a
vegetarian for some years and I still
don't eat battery chicken it changed
your politics doing that experience well
what changed my politics was they had
too many volunteers on the keyboards and
I actually spent quite a lot of time on
the way on the West Bank this was 1974
and although the occupation was nothing
like it is today it was a sobering
experience and I worked out that I
wasn't happy with that
[Music]
great I mean I've been interested in the
ministry Palestine conflict you call
yourself a Zionist I didn't really after
that I would I I don't think the Zionism
labor was ever very bit you know
Zionists I admit some I think wasn't
really a big thing in Britain until
after the six-day wards seven so you
know we had a there was a blue and white
tin in the corner which was you know
money for Israel but it was only after
the Six Day War when people started
going to Israel Jews started going to
Israel going to Jerusalem there I think
things began to change people began to
emigrate my father's sister emigrated to
Israel that's one of the reasons why I
went to work on the kibbutz I went to
stay with my arm you know I have cousins
including one my own age but I was quite
disillusioned by the
experience in fact because first of all
the kibbutz was not the fantasy it
wasn't no it was you know they didn't
have well the first thing was they
didn't have children's health you know
one of the things would attract women
was the idea of not living with my
parents of living with other kids being
a more independent and you know they'd
abolish them I mean I mean now I
probably wouldn't be so enthusiastic
about the concept I liked living with my
kids yeah when they grew up
so it was disillusioning and it it may
am so my politics evolved I mean part of
the reason no I do not describe myself
as design no no it's part of the reason
part of the reason that it's important
to talk about this is interest to talk
about this is obviously the Labour Party
has this huge problem with anti-semitism
a moment in your at your you're all sort
of key in it seems to me in negotiating
between sort of misunderstandings if
that's what it is or also that you know
how you speak to how you speak into a
situation of genuine anti-semitism on
the left and you've said before you
think this is a real problem can you say
something more about it I know it's a
real problem I see cases you know I'm
now a member of the local party National
Executive we have cases coming to us and
you know they are cases of real
anti-semitism which no one could see as
anything else if they saw them you know
we can't you know because of data
protection legislation we are not
allowed to show the effort and why they
don t go to such a particular problem
well you say such a particular problem I
don't think it has actually got such a
particular I mean it's a it's a it's a
real problem for us it's a it's a very
difficult problem but I don't think it's
particular to the Labour Party I think
it's present in society I think it's
present you know my dad when he was a
Tory thought the Tory Party was an
anti-semitic party he supported it
because it was an economic interest he
always thought it was a problem in the
inventory party and indeed it is as is
Islamophobia very strongly in the
problem in the Tory Party but there is
no point in when you when there are when
there are genuine accusations of
anti-semitism you know that are real
just to point the finger at someone else
and say yes but
you know you have to acknowledge you
know when when people make make
accusations of racism and you have to
take them seriously and investigate them
and if they are valid then you have to
you have to deal with that and it is no
point some of them this is what about
eree does some of the racism on the left
as it will grow anti-semitism on the
live grow out of a particular attitude
towards israelis well i think i it is
absolutely related to the
israel-palestine conflict because you
know up surges in anti-semitism in
society are related to periods of great
attention in that conflict so you know
when they wait you know the lebanon in
the war in lebanon the you know attacks
on Gaza you know absolutely make it
worse but you know that isn't enough of
an answer because you know why white
should people hold Jews in in Britain
responsible for the actions of the
Israeli government you know they don't
government most Jews in Britain
disapprove of of the occupation you know
they understand that settlements are an
obstacle to peace and so you know it's
quite wrong it's it's as wrong to hold
Jews responsible for that is you know
for the actions of the Israeli
government as it is to hold Muslims
responsible for the actions of any any
the government of any Islamic country or
organization so we'll move on from this
so you you you you you get your room
left isn't quite early on yeah and then
you go to uni and so forth is it
developed during that sort of early your
early years it certainly did I mean by
the time I got university I was already
I would say a Bennet you know I was I
was attracted to the the economics of
the alternative economic strategy I had
been a member of the campaign for Labour
Party democracy for join that actually
just after I started University
you know that was that was the influence
of some people in the young socialist
branch that I was in which was you know
we used to meet every week you know we'd
go out campaigning we talked politics if
that was a very formative experience
there you know having an active heared
section you know which which engaged in
political discussion not just canvassing
which unfortunately was what young labor
did for a number of years and then how
you were quite young when you went to
work for Tony Benn I was I was well I
was straight out of university I I got
very much involved in the campaign for
then the party democracy and that led
you know we we were winning various
things at the time we that was when we
won a wider franchise for the election
of the leader you know essentially
prepared the ground for the method that
eventually elected Jeremy Corbyn as
leader of the Labour Party
we we we changed the way or the Labour
Party changed the way it's selected it's
and beans to make them more accountable
to the party you know there was a
division them as there was in in 2015
you know between the way that the
parliamentary party saw things and the
way that the bulk of the memberships or
things and you know that did lead to
some conflict in the party which I know
is never good for political parties in
you know when it comes to election time
one of the things that as I'm fascinated
about your me about your story is that
your your wife died when she was she was
39 which you know and then use my kids
were were were little they were seven
eight and then you spent a long period
of time basically looking after your
kids didn't you that was well they also
spent a lot of time looking after me
and you know kids do that kids care
about yes
and you know somebody want to have
cancer is that she had breast cancer
yeah she'd she was dying she she was
diagnosed and survive for years yeah a
treatment a year of normality and then
she got secondaries and died a couple of
years later and it was it was very hard
time yeah I I imagine that those things
shape a person politically and socially
as much as any of the other experiences
you might have hard to describe well
it's I I can't describe how I I you know
I I don't mind talking about it you know
I had a job interview about a year or
two after she died and I was asked as
you do get asked in job interviews
sometimes you know what was my greatest
success and I said it was my wife's
death in the sense of making it as good
a death as it could be and I don't think
that was very helpful in the job
interview it rather terrified the
interviewers it was really how I felt
and actually the way that I got through
that period was boring you know once she
was diagnosed as having secondaries you
know we knew what she was going to die
of and we knew it wasn't going to be
very long and you know when the kids
talk to us about it we answered their
question so you know when my youngest
Ben one one day when they were having
their team and sitting around the table
and he said to birth mummy when you die
who's gonna pick me up from school
well Beth actually laughed and we ended
up all laughing because it was it was
funny I mean it was it was wonderful the
way actually a child can ask a basic
simple question which matters
you can answer it easily and so we
talked honestly to our kids and I was
very focused on making it a good death
I'm actually it was a good death
she died at home with her family all
around her and sorry and you know we
moved on from it and I mean you know I
my family is now really really important
to me I could never imagine you know
it's the thing that most shapes my
politics in many ways yeah you know my
kids know all by the way join the Labor
Party they all supported Jeremy Corbyn
they're members of momentum they call me
crazy
they still look after me actually and
they still a very mutually supportive
[ __ ] when you go from a situation where
you're close to someone like Tony Benn
and there's your christ quite on a power
there and then you're spending some
years washing socks and taking people to
school and I taught my kids to wash
their roads actually no I made them sort
their socks right you know you how you
can never match so I'm still asking
about and they took over their own wash
when you go like you know you had go
from important thing and then your ego
takes a bit of her a bashing along to
come through that well listen I'm asking
for a friend who used to meet some
Paul's Cathedral and then he and then he
left her and went to her and there's
grandma's job and it's like hard to go
to those sorts of it's hard making those
specific jealous we all have to do a
mixture of things in our lives you know
the most important people in the world
and I'm certainly or one of them you
know have to they have to do their
washing they after you know cook and
clean and stop sometimes
you know these difficult personal
circumstances are the most different
things to manage in all of our lives of
and I mean look people raise this as as
if you know my life must have been very
hard and difficult but actually I've I I
don't feel that about my life I feel
I've been incredibly privileged you know
I I have lived probably in a very small
window where I've never been asked you
know I've never experienced directly
experienced war I know other people
haven't lived in terrible wars in my
life but I've never been directly
impacted on them you know my my parents
grew up during the war but most of their
lives were were in peacetime you know I
live in one of the richest countries in
the world I had a very privileged
education you know I have a very loving
family it's the sort of thing people say
about lefties as a gotcha isn't it that
sort of thing is as it's as if it's some
sort of there's some sort of hypocrisy
about having that that's sort of I've
read a cover things you know aimed at
you that have that as it's a gotcha idea
oh he's got a few quid you know we went
to a posh school don't you know I don't
there's a lot of things I no longer read
and you know I don't often look at the
Sunday Telegraph anymore or the Daily
Mail I don't read the comments on my
social media feeds there's a lot of
nasty stuff on that the only time it
right you know I really get exercised
about that stuff is when it's about my
kids and there have been some stuff
about my kids which is really unpleasant
yeah you be you became for a certain
sort of journalists you became a sort of
hate thing I mean they always like to
find hey figures but there's a time when
you become the sort of like you know
you're the boogey man that's gonna it's
gonna get you my kids don't know me
though you know
[Laughter]
let's let's move on to momentum let's
talk about let's talk about momentum and
what was the idea behind the founding
government you know when Jeremy I was in
the meeting when Jeremy agreed you know
to you know it was his turn to stand for
the leadership you know what to do
he didn't well he didn't want to believe
was he was accepting of the fact that he
he would be Logan's - it was yeah it was
his turn and of course he only thought
it was about being on the ballot paper
he didn't actually think he would even
be a candidate so and he you know I
think he did rise to that challenge he
rose in every occasion to the charge but
he was he never wanted the job you know
it was never he never he'd never set out
for the job he didn't try you have no
ambition to be leader of the Labour
Party and in my view that's a good thing
that's you know it makes him fit for the
job in my view and so the momentum
itself is a sort of set up as a sort of
well I Torian God well the praetorian
guard you know they're dangerous things
I think they killed 12 of the Emperor's
they were supposed to protect so it's
not a baturin go no the idea happened
right we didn't know that we were going
to win I thought we'd do quite well and
we know we knew we would have access to
the Labour Party's membership database
we would be able to communicate we'd be
able to collect data our own and the
idea was we would use that data to build
an organization to promote the ideas
that were you know the essence of the
campaign and you know and that's that's
what we did do but we won we won the
election as well and so you know it was
a an astonishing campaign I wish I could
say we'd organized it you know that way
but it was spontaneous people were you
know
you know really you know motivated and
infused by hearing political ideas that
they hadn't heard before you know that
there was an alternative to austerity
I'm here articulate and the connection
between him and young people was
particularly the mention is often seen
as a you I don't think we call you a
young person if first I'm afraid but but
studies it's seen as a young person's
movement I think it may seem as young
comes I'm in actually Momentum's
membership is probably representative of
the population as is the labor
partnership didn't used to dismember
ship you know only a few years ago I was
the youngest person I label my labor
party branch meeting and I am 61 now you
know it shouldn't have been like that
but it was like that but lame party now
has a representative its representative
of the population and you know young
people are an enthusiastic part of that
and if you come to Momentum's offices
and if you came to you know the phone
banks and other things in those
leadership campaigns in me and me in the
2017 general actually you would have
found loads of young people and of
course that is really if you just
because I didn't think we were going to
have a generation that was going to take
on you know if you like the banner of
socialism and so to have this sudden
influx is enormous Lee you know
inspiring for me actually and you can
learn so much from people who had a very
different political experience for me
you know my politics have changed as a
reserve quite a lot as a result of
talking to these you know great young
people who helped run moment that there
is a one of the things that's leveled
against momentum is that there is a sort
of there is a bit of a solid nasty
political edge to it that when you have
that you know there's this you know
branch meetings and so forth everybody's
being ousted and announced and there's
there's a culture of that that there's a
culture of denunciation I'm more
left-wing the new type of thing which we
this is something that said broadly
about momentum you know you're you're
perfectly nice bloke and I just like I'm
just trying to connect all those things
up it's just not true well the
allegation why of course is made and you
know I'm sure there are local party
meetings which are not pleasant in which
people are nasty to each other that does
happen I mean you know that there can be
fault on both sides in those situations
I think that when the membership of the
Labour Party suddenly troubled you know
there was quite a lot of hostility from
the old membership towards the new
membership and suspicion and you know
new members were not always made welcome
honey in some ways I think it's
understandable you know the membership
change the politics of the membership
change and you give names it's not
comfortable
no in April who and like change I mean
we are history here today after leg
party got trounced last night trounced
fifth in bowls over I mean you know if
you gone fifth in bowls over what how
are you gonna square a energetic young
broadly remainer type of young people in
a party with the sort of working-class
heartlands who think differently how
does how do you make that how do you
earn that together well you know it's a
it's a it is difficult and if you look
back at 2015 when these young people
join the Labour Party in a spirit of
hope and optimism
you have to also sometimes learn how to
to to deal with defeat and to pick
yourself up after those to be and
believe me and I've had lots of
experience of that over the last forty
years and I think there was a big change
in 2016 when Jeremy was challenged and
we had the second leadership campaign
because people didn't want you a lot of
the new members you know they felt
alienated by their the old members who
weren't welcoming but they did and
therefore they didn't engage very much
actually with the party they'd come to
momentum meetings they'd go out
campaigning but you know they they
didn't want to do something that wasn't
where they weren't made to feel welcome
and then there was this suddenly wasn't
suddenly attacked because the attacks
had started as soon as Jeremy was
elected but when the challenge came it
made people a bit hardened you know and
a bit tougher and Brixton and learn
weapon Isis again and we all don't
weaponize his life I mean I'm really
interested in your position on brixey
because you know you you work for Tony
bed is a lever
Michael Mitra definitely Euroskeptic
Jeremy been a Jeremy Corbyn I think is a
lever you know you have all of these
left with me was you you you feel I mean
I said to you before you feel a bit like
a you feel a bit like I leave it to me
but you denied it
well I'm voted remain a campaign for
remain I'm I was a year a skeptic
remainder you know I I I'm an
internationalist through and through i I
I feel completely European I mean
actually that's a that's only from my
Jewishness you know I mean I upon a
schism you know nationalism has not been
good for Jews I don't think the
nationalism of Jews is good for
Palestinians I so I do have the
existence of the State of Israel not
about the existence of the State of
Israel it's it's a comment about you
know I don't see any conflict between
opposing anti-semitism and supporting
Palestinian rights and statehood and I
and I do and it's raining bamboo is a
form of nationalism you just support
well yeah yeah well in one sense it is
but I think you have to look at the
politics of the at the beginning of the
State of Israel which was in the a which
was you know followed on from the
Holocaust and the reason that the UN
voted to istituto for partition is
because actually neither Britain nor the
u.s. nor other western country on out of
the Allied countries wanted to take in a
load of Holocaust survivors and you know
and that was the only option I'm
interested in your attitude to the
nation-state about this so with regard
to Palestine and we've begun Israel and
whatever it is because I'm the one thing
you say I'm I'm I mean this relates to
practice it doesn't you know and I'm
against nationalism it's a terrible
thing and you lead us down the path
towards that being racist but on the
other you were saying things like I
think it's terribly important that we
have you know national state for
Palestinians and the word national I
mean you know we would vote for me the
thing about Jews and Palestinians and
Israel Palestine is that Jews should
have the same right to statehood as
other as other as other people you know
do I feel that there has to be a Jewish
state well if there was some other
settlement which involved people living
in the same state I wouldn't a jet to
that but if you know but I want there to
be a viable state in which Jews can live
can live I guess the peacefully and
happily as I want for Palestinians the
question I'm getting at really is
actually not about Israel Palestine is
about this whole idea of nation okay
so I so I'm trying to press you on this
because there'll be lots of people who
would see themselves working class labor
people who would see themselves as
patriotic whom the nation-state is
important it's a sort of a limit of
democratic legitimacy and then you sort
of association with with something more
like racism which is I'm trying to work
out what the whole idea what the what
your valuation of the nation-state is
I'm in favor of democracy and democracy
has to exist at every level you know
from the community upwards you know
including the state including I might
say Europe one of my biggest criticisms
of of the EU and it's reason one of the
reasons why I describe myself as US
captain it's because there is so little
democracy in the EU actually the power
in the EU is really held by the Council
of Ministers in which ministers act in
national interests you know and in it
actually embeds the than the the concept
of the nation-state in the structure of
the European Union I feel more
comfortable quite frankly with a federal
Europe which was democratic where the
Parliament had more power I think
there's a there's been a real democratic
deficit in Europe you know which has you
know empowered ministers to pursue the
national interest and as empowered the
Brussels bureaucracy I'd sooner see it
democratized I'd feel more happy about
that so I I'm not I'm not auntie I'm not
auntie the nature say but nor am i nor
do I feel it's it's a very important
thing for me so we have the National
Health Service which we would want to
love it is linked its name and in its
concept with the idea of it being the
health service within a particular
nation people's national identity ism is
important a lot national identity is
important to a lot of other people well
after that Horan just and they of the
nation together I'd really I think I
think that well national identity am the
political structures
the nation is you know one could argue
and indeed historians do argue that the
nation is actually the product of the
state it follows the state doesn't
receive it yeah and you know I think
that's pretty true actually
um okay I've got some questions here
from from people in the audience come on
this is this is this one you should like
knock knock out apart really so Anna's
asks what should what would socialist
future that I can within the Corbin
I think it has to be democratic every
level I've just been been talking about
that you know from communities you know
to the nation levels in between
workplaces empowering consumers
democratizing public services
nationalized industries I think it the
state has to take responsibility for all
aspects of the well-being of people and
the functioning of the of the economy in
the interests of people and not profit
and I think we have to have the state
has to take responsibility for the
quality of public services and I want to
see and more equal distribution of
income and wealth because I think that
is the cornerstone of a healthy happy
population so when you say it's
democratic when 52 percent of people
vote to leave the European Union do you
think we should we should do that well
we I think the Labour Party in 2015 when
when David Cameron proposed the
referendum as a way of resolving
conflicts within the Tory Party nothing
to do and because he didn't think that
it would go the way it went the then
leader of the Labour Party Harriet
Harman was the acting leader accepted
that the Labour Party would said the low
party would accept the result I think
having done math it would be very wrong
not to respect the result so you know I
I accept that position does that make me
less of a remainer
no well we've already had a second
referendum the first referendum was in
1974 far so another I was three weeks
too young to vote another you know if we
had another referendum then it would be
the best of three do I think we should
have it I I think it may be the only way
that we can resolve the outcome and if
it's proposed in that way then I think
it can be justified I
the trouble is you know the demands from
almost the beginning for a people's vote
you know from people who deposed
Brax it does look to a lot of people you
know who voted for brexit as just simply
a way of overturning the last referendum
and I think you have to understand the
reasons why people voted for brats in
you know if they felt angry they felt
let down
you know they felt that their air you
know the areas in which they live have
been neglected by successive governments
and unfortunately I think you know that
is not without foundation i i i i feel
that the Blair government you know
played its part in that you know under
blares watch I you know we like you know
having got a tremendous election victory
in 1997 we then proceeded to lose 5
million working-class votes because
people felt that that a layer of
government was not doing rexis revenue
is is to is to split apart an alliance
between between the Labour Party and the
working-class traditional work implies
that's one of the things that threaten
well that's you know that's why it is
proposed by the far-right that's why you
know frankly Nigel Faraj is exploiting
it as an issue you know he he isn't on
the side of the working-class you know
he was a city trader he's that's not his
politics you know but unfortunately the
far-right exploit the insecurities of of
working-class people for their own ends
and I'm extremely worried about the rise
of the far right that was that was
evident in the results that we saw last
night
do you think that that's close to saying
you were very careful about what you say
here because and presumably you know
Labor Party comes fifth in Bolsover you
don't say you not a racist because you
voted for Nigel Farage that's not going
to win people back it certainly isn't
and I wouldn't say that no but it's not
benefits but there is a so lots of
working-class people voted for Nigel
Farage you think Nigel Farage's a racing
so there is like what I didn't quite
mean I think I might go far as may well
alright so now comes a question but like
so I'm just trying to work out how you
it's you just you're quite closed her to
steering people in the direction of
thinking that working-class people who
would vote for exit party were racist no
I think that working for us people were
angry that so little had been done for
their for their communities for the
areas in which they live you know they
they you know large swathe of England
and Wales and you know have have seen
the industries that completely dominated
those areas just disappear as a result
of the policies of governments and I
don't think the Blair government did
enough to put that right because they
left too much to the market they
believed that markets could solve these
things I don't believe that I think the
state has to take responsibility for the
well-being of communities and the proper
function of the economy I'm fascinated
by what your day would think if you if
you if your day was now and you're gonna
have a lot of these sorts of
conversations told to me like
conversations you've had with your dad
or like that you'd what would your would
your dad be more persuaded by you know
do you think you could and I think he
did come to be more persuaded I think he
did come to be to accept that I wasn't
just a bolshie teenager anymore hand
[Music]
he was a benevolent Tory I I it maybe he
wouldn't even bear to my mum did switch
actually my mum from God 1983 was a
Labour voltage eroded labour for the
rest of her life so I think I might have
been able to switch my dad in the end
yeah boaty teenager devotee 804 mod
abates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute's of arson ideas
at IAI TV
you